[Applause]
thank you and good morning everyone I'm
delighted to welcome you all to business
connect
as a business and trade secretary I
don't think it's impossible I don't
think it's possible you
'd Act
something that I'm bringing you into my
new position heading up the government's
primary department for business
engagement
to that end it is fantastic to see so
many Business Leaders in the audience
and thank you very much
see us
today is
a business Community with ministers
and where the governor should be looking
to make your license again
for business pro Enterprise
economy
himself
thank you well good morning everybody
welcome here today pro-business
[Music]
and we're all here today because
government can't do that alone we can
only deliver that growth and if we all
work together with you now I know the
last year has not been easy
change a war in Ukrainian energy crisis
returning
[Music]
people looking forward to today's ahead
now our job is to build on that positive
momentum
and that's why we need to create the
conditions for all of you to succeed to
drive that growth we need to make sure
that the UK is the best place to start a
scale or to grow a business
and we're doing that in a few ways first
of all we need more investment that's
why the chancellor ensure that we have
the lowest rate of corporation tax in
the G7 but combined with that
introducing full expensive so this is
pretty much the most attractive place to
invest anywhere in the world
research
agency Arya but we're also performing
our r d tax credits to make sure your
businesses are actually innovating so
for every pound we invest you invest
more alongside us
radiation
think about it the industries that are
driving growth changes
Financial Services in all those areas
and more
here
we also need to make sure that we keep
training
partnership for the first big
non-pacific economy to producer
growth
companies can be part of it take
advantage of it
most importantly
we need to make sure that all of your
businesses have access
skills and The Talented unique
and we used to in the past because it's
not linear anymore
we need to make sure that at every stage
of people's careers they get the support
the investment of AD to get the skills
they need to empower your businesses but
alongside that
we aren't apologetically want to make
sure that this country is a beacon for
the world's most successful talented
people
around the world to come here to
research to study to create new
businesses to come and work in your
growing companies that's the migration
system that it will do now if there's
one OverWatch
from today is this
background
I say that
because I know this government knows
that it's you it's your businesses
that create the Jaws
the opportunities and the prosperity
that our country depends on
so that's what we want to talk about
today
we're here to listen to all of you to
understand your views and then crucially
to make sure that we act on them because
I know that you want what I want
thank you very much
[Applause]
Kudos is very important for all of us
and happy you
and here you have represented the you
know businesses across the UK
how can government and businesses work
together to move it as private capital
which is so much more important today
brilliant right now
International services
as well
[Music]
two new
two million people do you know what's
even more interesting
goes to you is that industry allows our
companies to get the money they need to
fuel their expansion so it plays an
incredibly important part in delivering
our future growth so what are we doing
well one thing we're doing and I can see
uh Amanda here in the front row is after
brexit
like that
[Music]
right who's next
perfect yes
and
[Music]
um
yeah Industries
and
visiting the London School Academy which
is a school in North London that's
creating the next generation of all
those people they're so optimistic about
their Futures and we need to make sure
that we're replicating institutions like
that across the country so young people
from lots of diverse backgrounds
for years
right who is next
yes
[Music]
it was the biggest challenge and
opportunity is how to measure that was
into UK supply chain as well as it reads
and Industry and the government working
together can do to ensure we could
always imagine yeah Keith thank you
congratulations
in the UK now
you have the largest hospital we have
the second largest
um
certainty in these transition Industries
[Music]
I want to make sure that again
to create the new product services
foreign
[Music]
here at home
yes sir
everyone is
so my CEO and family contexter my
question to you is how can the UK
government support the acceleration for
startup scale UPS here in the UK both
for our midterm goals uh domestically
but also uh internationally yeah because
this is the burning question
we know we are brilliant at starting our
businesses
[Music]
this is incredible
for a couple of years
please
internationally to come partner with us
yes
over there
today
um
and we love uh we love your approach
these problems in the last month or so a
large language models have been
Unleashed a lot
which is already
right
the foundation models models so you know
I'll be talking a little bit about that
later today
um but your ballpoint is absolutely
right you know sovereign
leader
nor many other countries
I think that
yeah
and we're living in an interconnected
um world so I'd like to hear more about
what the government
or if you don't mind thank you yeah
relationship
s with India
live right yeah
Over The Line
I talked about earlier
to make sure that they work for all of
you work for Aboriginal consumers
agile
right
[Music]
all right that's um
I've got somebody there yes
um
obviously in this room we have many
major businesses uh represented a lot of
innovation companies also represented
but if you're the large number of small
medium-sized companies
in this country we're only about 500 000
which are micro companies
governments
small business
es
and that story is replicated up and down
the country right the majority of
employment in our country happens
business
ES
a year
opportunity
outside of the EU we can design
procurement rules
so for the first time
the first time
to
focusing ordinances and their needs one
of the bits of feedback we had back was
when you replied to lots of government
contracts you have to keep filling out
all your details again and again and
again create a new profile for your
small business multiple times
30-day
so that's the kind of very practical
transformative thing is support
foreign
right
because we care about this in businesses
right right lots of hands um yes
huh
foreign
the largest UK fashion brand and we
travel
businesses export it is somewhat
perverse that on the day that we left a
decision
to remove
the UK at least to try to shorten the
destination in Europe
today
um
foreign
the
uh
engagement
[Music]
and hopefully you guys can see from
today's events
from the government
the country and you know I hope you have
a good day where you've been comfortable
with your practical ideas we will take
them away and gave them properly and
disruptively and make sure that we can
yeah
I'm really grateful to you as well with
almost 250 um
and engage
many of you all know him
um
okay yes
my question is related to how the
government can support businesses like
us that have Global emissions beyond the
UK Shores
of things
and so on
but that this should include tactical
things like allowing us to passport our
licenses
Global businesses
relationships with other countries
because unlike lots of countries economy
around
[Music]
for example services that that
represents one of the most ambitious
services
qualifications it sounds incredibly
simple but actually if the country
weapons recognizes the professional
license in architecture something like
that it means all our amazing people
here and Professional Services to then
do what they do around the world and
that's what we're working at so they're
part of our you know training is you
don't have to necessarily always do the
big trade deal right because of
complicated but when we can find
individual sectors and individual
licenses of all of the patients that we
can get Mutual recognition for that's a
small sensible thing to do often doesn't
take as long yeah opportunities
next uh yes
thank you sir good morning to you my
name is
San Francisco
my question is how can you help put
early businesses like ours
scale up in other markets and also be
competitive or at least be able to
compete you know coming from the UK
sometimes when you're in a big country
like America it is very hard to stand
out
and we try your best
strategy to help us do that if so how
how yes we do uh it's called breaks it's
called break and we have a fantastic
team of people from business who serve
on our Council and that that campaign
that organization funded by government
that their job is to promote UK and UK
businesses around the world universe
[Music]
all these things
um
foreign
[Music]
universe
a few years ago to do a review of the
female production yeah
it's really worth reading it brings to
life shines Delight on some of the
barriers that are put there and lots of
recommendation for us about what we can
do to try and address some of those
things
so if you look at the number of
companies
two or three times more than it was um
similar question
and one of them was finance and whether
it's harder for female entrepreneurs
about one of the reasons that we
extended seis our tax relief or
investing in very reality businesses
female houses she talked about networks
and mentorship
it's being something that was really
important and yeah
to continue to grow and
because
we want to make sure that no matter your
background you know no matter whether
it's whether you're a little man whether
it's where you're from a different part
of the country
there's so much talent in our country
and we're missing out we're not giving
everyone an opportunity to fulfill that
potential so that's what we're going to
try and do and you know and hear all
your ideas
together because
we can deliver it right okay I mean
we're almost half times yes sir yeah
ECA
[Music]
Industries
foreign
[Music]
opportunity for us
and particularly
like the work that it would do yeah
right because
this is one of those areas companies
[Music]
treatment
about it
yes
across
it's gonna be amazing to see what you do
over the next month
right
[Music]
um
we want your feedback
so thank you for being here today enjoy
the rest of the day and I'll see you
soon